hayange en moselle villeneuve loubet
dans les alpes-maritimes à béziers et à
vias dans l'hérault à beaucaire dans le
gard dans toutes ces villes les maires
l'ont dit ils ne participeront pas au
contrôle du pass sanitaires dans les
bars et les restaurants à fréjus par
exemple c'est l'édile david rachline qui
s'est élevé contre cette disposition en
publiant mardi une tribune dans valeurs
actuelles il est revenu sur les raisons
de son choix sur notre antenne regarder
je ne souhaite pas que la police
municipale de fréjus participent à ce
flicage généralisé en réalité ce monde
en tout cas super ou dans lequel tout se
va être vont être surveillés par des
policiers par des gérants de restaurants
tout cela n'est pas acceptable par
priorité est claire c'est la lutte
contre la délinquance contre les vols
contre on pour l'ordre public de manière
générale et certainement pas ce flicage
alors se pose tout de même une question
ces élus locaux ont ils le droit de ne
pas faire contrôler le pass sanitaire
parce que si le maire agit au nom de la
commune il exerce également des pouvoirs
au nom de l'état selon le code général
des collectivités territoriales le maire
est chargé de la police municipale sous
le contrôle du préfet il est aussi
chargé toujours sous l'autorité du
préfet de l'exécution des mesures de
sûreté générale et les mesures de lutte
contre la pandémie dont le pass
sanitaire rentre clairement dans ce
cadre là la police municipale est par
ailleurs bien habilité à procéder à des
contrôles dupas sanitaires comme le
prévoit le code de la santé publique du
coup à tous ces maires qui demandent à
leurs agents municipaux de ne pas
contrôler le pass annie terre on
pourrait leur reprocher de manquer à
leurs obligations et de ne pas faire
appliquer les lois de la république ces
édiles et pourrait même être suspendu
c'est une mesure extrême mais c'est déjà
arrivé par le passé sauf qu'en réalité
rien de tout cela ne se produira tout
simplement parce que eh bien les maires
ont toute compétence pour décider des
missions qu'ils confient à leur police
municipale
deux types de règles pourraient nous en
empêcher une interdiction claire dans
une loi ou un décret ou une contre
indication du préfet or nous n'avons vu
ni l'un ni l'autre et justement aucune
injonction précise n'a été formulée par
l'état
le ministère de l'intérieur confirme
d'ailleurs que si les agents de police
municipale sont bien habilité à procéder
à des contrôles dupas sanitaires
rien ne les y oblige idem du côté des
préfectures qui pour le moment n'ont
pris aucune décision contraignante
vis-à-vis des mères la préfecture a
toujours mentionné qu'il s'agissait
d'une possibilité mais il n'est fait
nulle part mention d'une quelconque
obligation cela n'a pas empêché la
préfecture du var de condamner la
position du maire de fréjus décrite
comme je cite une manoeuvre politicienne
conclusion rien n'oblige les élus locaux
à demander à leur police de contrôler
les passes sanitaire cela dit ça ne
devrait pas changer grand chose pour les
administrés des communes réfractaires
qui reste contrôlable par la police
nationale et n'oublions pas que les
restaurateurs restent soumis à
l'obligation de contrôler les passes
sanitaires car oui nous sommes désormais
dans une situation où des citoyens sont
davantage tenu de faire respecter la loi
que certains policiers des policiers qui
eux à la différence des restaurateurs
n'ont pas à présenter de pas sanitaires
pour être autorisés à travailler